[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
looking at one of the most notorious
dubs in the history of anime if you're
too young or just we're watching anime a
decade ago you've probably never seen
the one piece for kids dub which first
aired on June 4th in 2004 for kids was a
production company that once upon a time
acquired the licenses for many popular
anime including one piece Pokemon Shaman
King yu-gi-oh and more the company is
infamous for producing what many have
called some of the worst dubs of all
time fast-forward to today and for kids
entertainment is still around but it's a
shell of the company used to be for kids
either lost or were forced to sell all
of their anime licenses to other
companies like Funimation and in 2012
they change their name to for licensing
corporation one piece in particular is
considered to be one of the worst dubs
in for kids history even employees who
have defended for kids have mentioned
how one piece is an extreme case that's
hard the reputation of the company so
what did four kids do to one piece that
brought them so much undying hate from
the anime community today we will try to
get to the bottom of this question by
looking at 10 ways for kids change one
piece before we go on there will be some
one piece spoilers for kids made 104
English episodes in all based on the
first 143 Japanese episodes which
approximately covers everything up to
the beginning of the sky island arc I'll
try not to spoil anything beyond that
point this is the first time anime
uproar is doing a video about one piece
so give it a thumbs up if you guys want
to see more videos like this one in the
future if we can get 1000 likes I'll do
a part 2 since there are too many
examples of questionable censoring to
fit it all into one video and we may
even do the same style of video for
other for kids does if you guys are
interested if you haven't already be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you know the second
we upload a new video
now let's out further
do let's get back into it the Fox
Network made a deal with four kids
entertainment on January 22nd 2005 and
as a result four kids took over the five
hours Saturday morning timeslot when I
was a little kid I used to love tuning
into for kids TV on Saturday morning
we're talking sonic X u yo shaman king
and even one piece I'm not going to lie
I loved watching these shows and this
was before I even knew the difference
between cartoons and anime I had no idea
that these shows were from Japan at all
however when I got a little older I
started to prefer watching Inuyasha
on Y TV or reading the Naruto manga
which my friend introduced me to when I
finally discovered Death Note
online before they even finish dubbing
it I loved it and it was the first time
I watched anime with subs I was only
like 13 years old at the time but I
liked how much sure these other anime
were and everything on for kids
including one piece just start to see
more and more childish to a point I just
didn't want to watch them anymore little
did I know at the time it wasn't one
piece that was childish it was the four
kids version of one piece that was
childish and it would take me over a
decade to figure that out what I was
watching was a heavily westernized
watered-down version of one piece that
was specifically targeting for kids as
lucrative 6 to 11 year old demographic
while in Japan one piece was for
everyone it scored consistently high
ratings with kids teens and even adults
and this is one of the major
discrepancies that would result in some
of the most infamous moments of
censorship in anime history now let's
look at ten changes for kids felt like
they had to make for their targeted
demographic and what those changes do to
one piece number one the music long way
to go by the gumgum
the English intro gets a mixed response
some people hate it and many fans
expected for kids to use an English
version of the original intro song we
are in the spirit of the Pokemon wrap
the intro consists of the famous
yo-yo-yo-yo chorus and multiple rap
verses that talk about how spongy is
cooking and chopper is doctoring to be
honest I like this intro when I was a
kid and it is still nostalgic for a lot
of people
although it definitely has a completely
different feel compared to the original
although it is fun hearing brought from
Pokemon nari the beginning there once
was a man named gold Roger and I like
that he says gold Roger left his
treasure in one piece
rather than in one place because I think
it ties well to the title of this show
however the bigger issue in my opinion
rests with the rest of the music used
for this show they replaced the original
symphonic score with synthesized music
that was sometimes reused from other for
kids dubs sometimes they don't even have
music which is problematic especially
during emotional moments if we take an
anime like Clannad the music is part of
the whole it makes to show what it is I
cannot imagine Clannad without the
amazing soundtrack in my view the music
is just as important to the overall
experience as is the animation so I just
can't get behind switching it with
reused on tailored music or just for
moving it all together anyways don't
give it up solo one piece of my city
moving on to number 2 westernization
there are many instances of four kids
trying to make the show appeal to
Western audiences one that stands out to
me is the instance with the rice balls
Zorro has surrendered himself to the
Marines in order to save a girl and her
mother
Zorro is tied up in the scorching Sun
and left to star the little girl he has
saved sneaks and embrace him some rice
balls however apparently rice balls are
too foreign for kids felt it was
necessary to replace the rice balls with
chocolate chip cookies they also felt it
was necessary to change the Marines into
the Navy in my opinion these are
completely unnecessary changes then we
get to bug use black crewmate some
people feel that there are black
characters and anime that are depicted
in a racist style of caricature
including mr. Popo from DBZ jinx from
Pokemon and dismember from buggies crew
to be honest I don't have a problem with
how four kids gave this character white
skin the history of racism in the West
explains why four kids didn't want to
risk offending anyone let me know what
you guys think about this in the
comments section below
personally I'm just glad they didn't
make him blue number three
no smoking and finally we get to the
lollipop I purposely picked this for the
thumbnail because for me this image of
Sanjay holding the lollipop is the face
of four kids censorship there's so much
to say about the infamous lollipop
first of all Sanjay is supposed to be
cool and his cigarette helped get this
across many of the coolest anime
characters of all time smoke including
spike from Cowboy Bebop and Onizuka from
GTO
if we look at an anime like honey and
clover mature characters and characters
who want to be seen as more mature smoke
in anime smoking tells us something
about the character maybe it's saying
that he's mature or self-destructive or
that he just doesn't care the point is
for the creator there is a reason that a
character is smoking they're trying to
get something across that being said I
get that they cannot have such a cool
character that young kids will want to
model themselves after constantly
smoking since the shoulders on at such
an early time and their targeted
audience was so young they couldn't have
gotten away with leaving the cigarette
in there but if they're gonna go through
with the show anyway at least make it a
toothpick or something less childish why
would they have one of the coolest
characters in the anime a 19 year old
dude at this point constantly sucking on
a lollipop
they also edited out cigars for other
characters like crocodile and smoker who
by the way was renamed to chaser and his
power was changed from smoke to steam
number four no drinking just like four
kids went out of their way to avoid any
reference to smoking they did the same
with drinking if there's one thing we
know about pirates it's how much they
love their alcohol and especially their
wrong but for kids couldn't just not
mention alcohol they had to specify that
every beverage was something else
something non-alcoholic to the point
where it was pretty jarring not only do
they change the colour of Captain
buggy's alcohol they also make him say
it's grapefruit punch
it's a special recipe grapefruit finds
at the gold roger bar smoker or perhaps
I should say chaser orders juice instead
of alcohol and since we're dealing with
pie
and alcohol is a daily part of a
pirate's life especially Zorro's this
results in many instances of censorship
where the color of the beverage has
changed and characters are often
pointing out that this is in fact juice
I'm about to drink juice and mmm that
was some good juice I think you can
start to see how this can get annoying
number five no suggestive content it
seems like there's a big difference
between Japanese culture and American
culture in regards to what constitutes
inappropriate content for children's
television programs you can see this and
other children's shows like Dragon Ball
I mean you can't just show polka dotted
underwear to Western children that would
be indecent just make them a pure and
proper pink yeah that's good as you can
see the change is always made perfect
sense you can even see the difference in
yugioh cards the American version adds
clothing and/or minimizes any cleavage
that is shown so no one should be
surprised to find out that four kids
made similar changes to one-piece
the mangaka for one piece a Cheeto order
shared his opinion on fanservice many
times in the question corner where all
the answers his readers questions in
between chapters in the one piece
volumes to make a long story short he is
unapologetic when it comes to fanservice
in one piece and he feels that any
healthy boy or man should not be scolded
or made to feel ashamed for his interest
in the female body as a result the
female characters in one piece are not
afraid to show some skin especially the
28 year-old Nico Robin for kids however
thought different so they added clothing
and removed any cleavage number 6 no
Christianity for some reason for kids
felt like they had to remove anything
even vaguely reminiscent of Christianity
so devil fruit became cursive fruit kind
of like how Satan from Dragon Ball Z he
became Hercule however some of this
censorship definitely goes too far for
instance I guess for kids that the logs
that Zorro is tied to in the Marine base
to closely resemble a cross and so the
top of the log was removed mihawk sword
and dagger were also changed for the
same reason how
ever what is perhaps the weirdest change
is how they changed miss merry
Christmas's name to miss Groundhog's Day
and recolored her Christmas tree necktie
to be purple and red I guess we should
just consider ourselves lucky that
didn't turn chopper 2 blue nose reindeer
into a groundhog as well
number 7 no real guns probably some of
the most bizarre instances of censorship
revolved around guns one piece is a
world filled with pirates in Pirates
have guns the Marines have guns to stop
the pirates who have guns
my point is guns are prevalent in one
piece and their presence makes for some
of the most intense moments in the
entire show
so how did four kids go about dealing
with this one well in many cases let's
just say their censorship backfired in
the process of censoring the guns they
robbed significant moments of their
intensity and sometimes the result was
downright comedic let's start by
comparing the Marines for the Navy you
should be somewhat intimidated by the
Marines because they're pointing guns
that are protagonists and sometimes at
the viewer in contrast the Navy are
pointing what appeared to be water guns
yes you heard me right
water guns what are water guns gonna do
so much for the gravity of the situation
if the stakes just went from oh my god
they might be shot dead - oh my god they
might get wet the true intended reaction
Oda's intended reaction is definitely
not coming across
but then for kids contradict themselves
and have the water does actually fire
bullets so what was the point of making
them look like water gun if anything
it's even more problematic that the Navy
disguised real guns as children's toys
in another instance captain Morgan's son
is holding a gun to Kobe's head in what
must be one of the most bizarre
decisions in censorship history for kids
changes the gun into this weird
contraption that looks kind of like a
rubber hammer on a spring it's hilarious
and it definitely doesn't look like it
could hurt Coby at all it's also funny
how they kept the guns handle exactly
the same now before we move on let's
look at a gun related incident involving
shanks and overconfident pirate draws a
gun at shanks shanks calmly points to
the gun and tells him that those things
aren't for threatening a second later we
see a gun go off and then we see that it
was shot by shanks his own crew member
who shot the arrogant pirate
in the head someone should have told
this guy when you had to shoot shoot
don't talk
what follows is an intense moment of
silence we get a shot of shanks in
serious expression and we see the man
fall dead to every bystanders shock now
let's compare this to the forças version
the same pirate aims a gun that shanks
his head except this one clearly has a
cork in it the lesson about not tracking
people with guns is absent instead
shanks tells him that these weapons ie
the cork on misfire at such close range
first off WTF but let's continue then
shank says that he admits they can still
give quite a scare so we have a
dangerous and experienced pirate who
loses an arm like it was nothing saying
that a court gun can be scary this is
followed by his crew member pulling the
trigger and the man falls like in the
original in this version however when we
get a shot of shanks of serious
expression he's heard snickering and as
the pirate falls down he says when he
wakes up
someone tell him it was a cat gun so
that serious moment that intense silence
that was imbued with so much meaning in
gravity is totally offset instead of a
death we got a guy fainting from a cap
gun and then just when you thought it
couldn't get any worse a guy says it was
alright home oh man that is bad
this scene really illustrates how much
is lost in the for kids translation how
mature themes and moments become bad
jokes as a result the four kids aversion
seems less like a faithful translation
and more like a parody of the original
stop whining landlubbers you're not
dealing with Saints here alright I think
we spent enough time on this scene
moving on number eight minimising
violence another thing that four kids
did regularly was edit violent scenes
that they felt were too graphic or
problematic in some other way we can see
this throughout the show for example
when Zorro gets bad by buggy or when
Luffy uses his sweat to fight crocodile
rather than his blood however one of the
most interesting and ridiculous examples
of censorship can be found in episode 1
when Coby starts freaking out and
telling Luffy that there is no way he
can be the Pirate King Luffy not only
sees Colby acting like a wimp but he has
to listen to someone
tell him that his life's ambition data
breach in one piece and becoming the
Pirate King is impossible Luffy can't
take it anymore and punch his Kobe in
the head when Kobe asks why he did it
Luffy says just because however through
this act of violence we can see just how
much Lucy's dream means to him although
he seemed like a pretty carefree guy up
to this point and remember this is the
first episode so we're still getting to
know what kind of character our
protagonist is this act of violence
shows Luffy's determination and how he
won't let anyone get in the way of his
dream it shows us just how much he does
care when it comes to becoming the
Pirate King this is a great instance of
characterization but it's completely
lost in the for kids version in this
version they edit away roofies hand
Coby thinks that Luffy is going to hit
him so he ducks and this Luffy clone
says I wasn't going to hit you oh so
what happened is that this character
does the exact opposite of what the
original loopy does so the question at
this point is can we even consider these
guys to be the same person at what point
is Luffy no longer Luffy this is just
one example but it's emblematic of a
larger problem through censorship or can
slowly but surely changes these
characters to the point where they're
almost unrecognizable and believe it or
not it gets worse
number 9 no deaths the decision to not
include important deaths not only alters
the tone of the show it also creates
unresolved issues for instance Bell
Amir's death is one of the most
emotionally charged moments in one piece
no lie
I just rewatched a section of the scene
for the video and my eyes are literally
watering and goosebumps are in overdrive
how Bella Mia cannot say that she
doesn't have a family even if it cost
her her life that last I love you before
she dies the death is a sad as Bella
means love for her adopted daughters is
beautiful not to mention that such a
charged moment plays a major role in
nominees characterization and the fact
that she joins the Arlen pirates after
that takes on even greater significance
however this one of the saddest and most
beautiful scenes is all lost in the for
kids version in this version captain our
long simply points at Bella mere and
offers her a nice room in a dungeon the
emotionally charged farewell is gone the
major event that shaped Nami into
she is is gone Bella Mir has been
captured which creates another huge
issue in the die Jesus or fictional
world that is created by the four kids
dumb Bella mere is alive and ready to be
rescued from prison after the straw has
to feet are long but they obviously
never do rescue her because that never
actually happened in the original she's
dead after all and for kids doesn't
address this Nami is transformed from
being a loving heartbroken daughter into
someone who would forget to rescue her
mother from prison these kinds of
changes are all the more painful to
watch because Oda is such a good writer
everything has a purpose and everything
is intertwined and this issue will be
all the more apparent as we address
number 10 the skipping of important arcs
and the creation of plot holes now let's
turn to Game of Thrones for a second
George RR Martin's has not finished this
book series and the show will most
likely finish before the series does
however george RR martin has a say in
how the show is run and communicates
with the creators he has let them know
how the series is going to end and is
present to make sure that discrepancies
or plot holes are not created because as
the creator he knows what can be left
out and what absolutely cannot be left
out
he knows what can be added and what
addition would jeopardize the continuity
and integrity of the story a major issue
with the four kids one piece dub is that
there is no communication between Oda
and the producers at for kids as a
result they should have followed the
Japanese anime as closely as possible to
avoid any issues if they really wanted
to skip some stuff they could have done
the research read the manga and try to
avoid filler or anime only episodes
however they took it upon themselves
without knowing what although was
planning for the future to take out
episodes that were canon episodes that
were directly taken from the manga among
other episodes the reverse mountain arc
and little garden arc were removed for
the purposes of this video let's focus
on the reverse mountain arc Laboon whose
story is packed with more fields than a
lassie film was reincarnated into an
iceberg that was then destroyed by luffy
even though it didn't look like it was
affected at all by the explosion in the
next frame it is completely gone without
a trace so in a few moments of bad
editing we just kept over Laboon
focus vivy the log post that they were
supposed to acquire there and more
obviously this creates immediate plot
holes because in whiskey peak changed to
misty peak by the way in the for kids
version
vivy was supposed to have already met
the straw hats and they're supposed to
have a log post at this point so instead
the log post community drops out of
Aesop's pocket hey what's that
and Sanji conveniently remembers how to
use it because chef zest told him about
it when they parted but he just happened
to forget until this moment I remember
this in order to say on the grand line
you'll need a compass they reuse all
themes to deliver this information as
well the problem with these kinds of
changes is that they snowball over time
and the discrepancies become more and
more glaring if you've gotten far enough
in one piece you know that there's also
a very important purpose that Laboon
serves down the line although there was
perhaps no way for for kids to know this
they shouldn't have assumed that canon
material could be taken out without any
consequences in a way they're lucky that
they only covered the first 143 Japanese
episodes before they stopped because as
they went on these issues would have
only been exacerbated and become harder
and harder to deal with eventually after
the fall of four kids
Funimation got ahold of the license for
one piece and their dub is much better
received than the four kids got one
Funimation had the benefit of seeing how
not to dub one piece and today on online
streaming websites you can only find the
Funimation version even the four kids
DVDs are hard to come by and some
episodes weren't even released on DVD it
seemed like for kids one piece was going
to disappear forever until someone
uploaded all the episodes on the
Internet
some people think it would have been
better if that never happened they wish
that the forças version would disappear
completely and I see where those people
are coming from there's no doubt about
it it's a bad dub and it did give many
people including myself the wrong idea
about one piece although it may resemble
the original visually this for Kids show
is not a - - or does one piece it's
something else entirely however
personally I'm glad that the four kids
version wasn't lost to us forever now if
it was the only
version that would be a problem but as
things stand I believe that this is an
interesting historical artifact for me
it is worth examining how companies like
for kids attempt to bridge the gap
between different cultures and age
groups I wouldn't believe some of the
changes for kids made to one piece if I
hadn't seen them with my own eyes the
changes are bizarre ridiculous and
unintentionally hilarious at times it is
so bad that it's funny if you want to
experience all this amazing world then
this is not the way to do it but if you
read or watch the original and just want
to kick back and watch a hilariously bad
translation then you might even enjoy
the four kids dub and hey some of you
might have grown up on this version and
it has the static value for you so you
enjoy it for that reason I'm not here to
judge but in the end just keep in mind
that this poor kids version says a lot
more about our own culture than it does
about anything else and that's it for
today's video guys thanks so much for
watching until the end if you're still
here and want to show your support drop
up in the comments if you enjoyed this
video
smash that like button and like I said
if we reach 1000 likes I'll do a part
two for you guys if you haven't already
subscribed what are you doing man hit
that subscribe button for more fresh
content and until next time see you
space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]